[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
first of all welcome secondly I was not
kidding I don't know if you read the
card back there but my sister because it
was the pilot I guess they kept showing
sneak previews of songs or something my
sister has been all over me and I kept
forgetting to a shame she loves your
song pill for this like she was like
where's the girl and then it didn't even
a point I just with the song like she
was like so much and she literally said
I don't want somebody else to sing it I
want her to sing it and that's what we
got serious like you didn't win it's all
unfolding like beautifully
honestly I I feel like I won you know
what I mean sometimes I feel like
there's no right way all the time to do
things there's no perfect way and my
whole life has been a series of being
told there's a door and me finding my
way in through a window really has been
forever and I fairs work on it and you
know what we're sitting right here I
just wanted to be a part in the room I
don't have to be a part of any one word
one third I just want to be there it's
fun to write with him he's incredible as
well Julian's
he really is he really is I'm amazing I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this